but they should make it a big boob yeah
like a big boob big old nipple you go in
and you can only get milk from the
concessions these are these are these
are big plays right here damn I just had
a stupid ass style they turn into a
giant boob and it's just like covered it
in men like ants they're just like
lashed onto it like they're like rubbing
it yeah and like no like try their
mouths yeah they're just like stuck on
it yeah
like leeches it's a boob it's a boobs so
like should do a show called like boob
like b-u-b with like a apostrophe over
the U or something okay and it's all
like boob related all right super artsy
the boob show comes out and I'm like
Alina we should go
no we should really go she's like you
come on you're sick you're like no it's
supposedly it's art it's amazing